my channel is sponsored by anchor which
means we will hear more from them in the
middle of this video hi everyone i'm
alan along with my channel uh it's time
for another q a i do these every two
weeks now i do one that's personal
questions and one that's gaming
questions this is a personal one which
basically means it's everything other
than gaming
if you want to ask questions for the
next one you can leave them in the
comments below that one will be all
about gaming but today we're getting
personal slash
they're not generally that personal
um
okay i guess i will probably move this
to the start of this video
um this is gonna be a really weird thing
to talk about right now for anyone who
doesn't have any of the context at all
but i also don't feel like i should be
the one to go into detail about the
context basically it pertains to uh an
ex-colleague of mine so let's just do
the question and then i'll see if i can
make this make sense i don't know
team j said do you have anything to say
about adam is it true that you didn't
unfollow him does that mean that we
should take that as you supporting him
uh
so
i have no interest in in talking about
this is
the true answer um i i have no interest
in it whatsoever uh but i also get that
people are are curious and um i
understand why these questions are
coming up right now so i've said this
before but people have somehow like
whittled it away to mean a lot less than
it did when i said it so i'm going to
reiterate this and then hopefully never
speak about this again there is more
than you are aware of none of these
people stopped associating with this
dude because they think he cheated on
his wife
it's nothing that simple majority of the
assumptions are incorrect and far too
kind the secrecy is not to protect adam
it is to protect other people this is
people's real lives with people they
really know you know so
um i hope that people can be respectful
of that
as complicated as i understand that it
is i really i really hope that people
can
try to give the people who continue to
provide you content at funhouse the
respect and i also just think it's worth
keeping in mind um
as weird as it is to do this in a
personal q a on my own youtube channel
that you do not really know these people
they are not really your friends uh
going through
and checking who said what and when and
who's following who at what time is not
necessarily a healthy thing for you to
be doing i'm not even trying to like
criticize people who are doing that or
criticize people who are coming up with
wild theories or some just which are so
off base and then sharing them with
others it's it's
more that i'm trying to express that
like i think you can put yourself in a
lot of harm's way as we've seen a number
of times over the last several years
um by idolizing anybody that you watch
on the internet myself included anybody
and that trying to dig very hard and to
speculate and to you know have these
thousand comments threads posts whatever
about this stuff is also potentially
damaging
to you in the long run that level of
investment in a stranger um i actually
was still following him but it's because
he made his account private and stopped
tweeting so i just forgot to unfollow
him it was definitely not any sign of
support
um
yeah i hope that's coming off
in a way that is caring which is my
intent i'm not trying to sound
passive-aggressive or anything like that
in saying that that is genuinely not me
trying to tell you to [ __ ] off and stop
talking about it while i would love that
i'm not trying to be that insensitive i
completely understand the curiosity and
how frustrating it is i'm trying to say
this probably isn't good for you none of
it is frankly just cancel the whole
metaverse so this is probably gonna be a
really weird start to this video because
um
now that i'm sort of in a bit of a
downer mood uh no offense to the person
who asked this comment to
jay
um
i think i'm probably gonna end the video
here
so
that means i'm stopping the recording
but there's more of the q a to go
because i'll have to edit it in a
reverse order um
so yeah
to the rest of the video i suppose yay
shiro 82 matt t damn it that's a gaming
question okay i'm gonna make one
exception hero82 matt t said is there
anything yet to be released in 2021
that's potentially a geotype contender
for you and if not what is your gty so
far okay i just okay this is it the rest
of it no games no gaming stop trying to
make me game i just wanted to say
inscription
i didn't even know what it was i just
tried it and and then ended up playing a
bunch of it and
is absolutely
like one of my front runners for game of
the year right now which is a game that
most you probably haven't even heard of
okay let me just throw that out there
inscription i'm just as confused as you
are about how much i ended up [ __ ]
loving this game it's incredible
i haven't finished it yet i'm maybe like
10 hours in now maybe eight but
damn all right personal questions only
mlp noobs have said if you weren't a
video game writer or a writer at all
what other profession would you pursue
that's an interesting one naturally i've
been asked a million times it's like if
you didn't work in video games what
would you do for a living and i've
always said i would just write somewhere
else because i am a writer i am not a
video game
i just happen to work in the games
industry because i love it
people don't often ask me what would you
do if you weren't a writer
at all
i've always had an interest in education
and education reform so i could see
myself in some capacity
i i don't know if that would require me
to be a politician though because that's
like a whole other thing but working in
some kind of
educational science um but before i
studied writing at university the first
six months of my degree were
psychology i've always had an interest
in psychology
and there was a pretty long stretch of
time when i was younger that i wanted to
be an astronaut
but i found out you can't be an
astronaut if you have asthma
which is devastating but maybe something
more in a scientific field like either
of those psychology or
something to do with space as it were
spashe it is time to talk about anchor
anchor is the number one american
charging brand with over 65 million
users around the globe and their slogan
with the anchor nano pro is charging
fast make it last the anker nano pro has
all-time protection even while charging
it has a temperature sensor and utilizes
intelligent software while charging
making the process safer and protecting
your phone but it also works three times
faster than the original 5 watt charger
you can charge an iphone 12 or 12 pro
from zero percent to 50 in just 26
minutes it's also 50 smaller than a
standard iphone 20 watt charger the
anchor nano pro provides more power
while saving space in your bag or while
plugged into a wall outlet it also comes
with four fresh finishes to suit your
lifestyle and is tailored to your iphone
speed and style if you want to learn
more about the anker nano pro check out
the link in the description huge thanks
to anker for sponsoring this video and
make sure you check out the link in the
description to get your very own anchor
nanopro john sheath said what's one
thing you want to check off your bucket
list the most okay directly related to
the last question my number one goal in
life numero uno is to go to space that's
it
i could be on a one-way trip tomorrow
and they could be like hey you can go to
space
tomorrow
but you'll die
i would still do it that's how serious i
am about wanting to go to space i just
want off
honestly you could be like the
likelihood of you living on impact which
is like five days from now are so slim
10 chance send me to the [ __ ] moon so
that's like the number one thing on my
bucket list
do i think i can accomplish that
realistically no
it's getting more accessible but you
still have to be rich and i don't really
see a universe
where i qualify as
rich enough
to go to space and also
if it's as expensive as it is right now
i can see myself
having an ethical moral dilemma
where i would be like but i could spend
this money
on anything that would be beneficial to
society maybe unless they set me up for
some kind of tests maybe they do need to
test asthmatics in space let's [ __ ]
do it but number one
go to space it's all i want in life
that's it
number two
i'd really like to visit bruges
i just i've just kind of always wanted
to go there it seems like a really nice
place it's really that's the hierarchy
of of the known universe for me is space
which means outside of our atmosphere
bruges
michael alston said so you're really
five foot ten
i am
yes i am five foot ten which is about
178 centimeters tall
some people say that i seem short
like i have some kind of short energy
based on youtube videos
i'm surprised by that i wonder where
that comes from because to me short
people are very loud and boisterous and
bubbly and energetic
and if i've ever come across as
energetic in any content i've ever made
i would be shocked i don't think anybody
has ever
said that to me once in my life but
maybe that's just how i associate small
people as somebody who is not short i am
tall for a woman naturally there are a
lot of women who are taller than me i'm
not the tallest woman in the world by
any stretch of the means
word by any means slash i just combine
those two things by any stretch of the
word or any means but yeah tall people
to me i associate as being
like low energy
it's like you can just fit more
lightning in those little tiny people
packages you know they're just they're
so short
i gotta expend all the energy in my
limbs it's five foot ten wingspan baby
whereas the short people all their
energy's like just out here like t-rexes
they're all just so bubbly and hype and
i just don't have any of that liam
transit have you seen dune part one if
so any thoughts along assembly have you
seen any of other villanov's films
like blade runner 2049 and arrival uh
yeah i love to do part one um
auditorily i don't know if that's a word
and visually i was very stimulated i
thought that dune was very satisfying to
watch that said
i found the story and the pacing a
little bit less compelling
um as somebody who has not read the
books uh not bad just slightly less
compelling but like visually beautiful
so many beautiful shots which naturally
as someone who has seen i think
virtually every single one of his other
films
he's very good at but the audio is well
um i saw it at imax
and the combination of like just that
giant big ol pretty screen
surround sound audio it was like a
delight to experience in a cinema and i
think it's my first time going to the
movies
in a really long time so
yeah i really enjoyed it i liked it a
lot chris pefloma said hi alana i really
enjoyed the short film you released
earlier this year do you have any advice
oh thank you by the way any advice on
doing creative projects in times of
stress and mental fatigue there are lots
of creative things i want to do for
myself but i often find my self-esteem
and feeling generally burnt out get in
the way thanks so i planned to release
three short films this year there is a
chance the second one will still happen
um i've already cast it the actors are
on board and i think that they will be
wonderful it is mostly written but i
need to polish it for sure
but it's also going to be a lot harder
and i ended up being super busy right
now crazy busy and the whole of november
is going to be the same and then
december is december so
i i imagine i will have released one
short film this year even though i set
myself the target of three so
my advice generally
is
if you're stressed or mentally fatigued
or you feel burnt out
that's okay you are not in a rush to do
creative things i think
you probably make the best things and
make the best decisions and and treat
yourself better if you are working on
them in times that are a little bit less
stressful you can always
push something
you can't push your health though so
you can always push
the creative thing that you need to do
um i wouldn't push it forever down the
road like i totally recommend getting
out there and creating something but you
can't push focusing on your mental
health or your physical health down the
road does that make sense what i'm
trying to say is those are things that
you should prioritize right now things
that you need to be doing right now so
that in the long run maybe you can have
more creative projects so you can do
more creative stuff um i would just try
not to put that pressure on yourself and
focus on
making sure you're okay right now and
then get to the creative stuff when you
are okay you have a little bit more time
and set that as a goal if like when i'm
feeling this way i'm gonna start working
on this because i think we burn
ourselves out by giving us ourselves too
much pressure as well i do also want to
say a lot of people ask me how i'm so
productive or how i do so many things
and uh
from my perspective i spend a lot less
time on social media than
a lot of people in my circles a lot less
time this of course is not true in all
cases and i'm being a bit reductive
people feel burnt out
in a lot of cases because of social
media i think that using twitter or
instagram too much track how many hours
you're using them on a day and that's
that's what i do i make sure i don't go
over an hour using them too much makes
you feel like you're working it feels
like a sense of productivity and
contributes to burnout
even though it isn't actually anything
worth burning yourself out for it's a
thing that i just want to blanket
recommend is spend less time on social
media highly recommend it you'll get way
more stuff done
and you may feel a lot better for it as
well because i think yeah the amount of
like new information all the time
um
and this sense of productivity i spoke
about makes us feel like we are working
more even if it's technically supposed
to be a leisure app it fully feels like
work and effort and you're producing
content for these companies so they can
make things engaging and sell ads
without benefiting really any of us but
that's obviously again generalizing for
sure there are a million ways to get
burnt out less social media in general
seems like a good call to me conor lola
said what's one writing trip in games
you roll your eyes at every time it
comes up obviously subjective but i
dislike when the protagonist has a baby
for no other reason than for it to be
taken away to provide some false sense
of motivation like dude i don't know you
are your boring poopy miniature
offspring ytf do i care seems like it's
always a cheap trick to garner an
empathetic response from players and
requires little to no buildup or emotion
i have never liked in video games when
uh the player character the protagonist
uh excuses away a mechanic i don't know
if that really counts as a trope but
it's something that i find
annoying so say there's something that
happens repeatedly to the extent that
it's repetitive and the protagonist goes
ugh this again it's like i get what
you're trying to do
you're trying to excuse the fact that i
don't want to do this gameplay thing by
making the protagonist say the same
thing as me but you're still making me
do the repetitive gameplay thing i think
that probably also is in line with like
not liking it when characters talk to
themselves too much um i prefer if they
have a protagonist uh sorry if they have
a companion character nearby that they
can talk to then to like constantly
talking to themselves um and and over
explaining things to you through
dialogue of course that's required it's
probably something in a lot of cases
that they find they need through play
testing but stuff like oh i better go do
this oh better make sure i do this
huh i saw that ladder over there i think
i prefer that that most often in terms
of design when it's triggered after a
while of you not doing anything but if
it's overdone it's definitely a little
bit frustrating uh okay well that is it
from me today everybody
i'm alana and i will see you guys next
month bye